alors bien sûr que tu est la première à
bas prix bas
on est au milieu de la nuit ta mère tu
appelles toujours si tôt le matin
seulement pour mon anniversaire c'est
vrai tu sortais avec un bébé oui maman
je sors avec un bébé et ça ne pourra pas
devenir sérieux entre nous parce que sa
mère est toujours dans les parages ne
mange pas de pain quand est-ce que tu
valence était ligne de robes de soirée
et le picasso de la mode
regarde ouais mais picasso n'en est pas
un découvert de milan à rembourser tu
est fiancée et tu maria dit tu veux
l'essayer au regarde ça passe pas bah si
c'est pas un signe ton âme soeur est
quelque part tu la trouveras quand ce
sera le moment
un daiquiri framboise glace et je vous
prie tu arrivé quelque chose
ce que j'espère c'est lancer ma carrière
acteurs au rockstar rockstar c'est
évident je me souviens toi la rockstar
ne pas l'oreille musicale ça c'est
dommage on m'a dit un jour de m'en tenir
au playback
tu penses que tu est exceptionnel que tu
es unique c'est ce qu'on appelle et
vivre le moment présent et je pense que
tu devrais essayer
[Musique]
c'est peut-être toujours été très clair
sur le fait que tu ne voulais pas te
marrer je sais si la clé du mois c'est
mon cadeau d'anniversaire
[Musique]
les armes ne tombent jamais amoureux des
femmes qui ne se prennent pas au sérieux
c'est déjà assez dur de trouver
quelqu'un avec qui j'ai envie de passer
le week-end alors imagine le reste bof
[Musique]
très bien alors on encourage à dans we
had an allegory nous a dit oui justin
quinn